with my work i want to create pieces
that engage community together
and allow us to
really celebrate something positive
and i love seeing how the action of
crocheting connects people together
[Music]
i'm oleg i'm an artist
and crochet is my technique
i was raised in a communist poland with
very limited access to any culture and
any public art
in 2000 i came to new york i was 22 i
had a backpack full of drinks like no
money and i was asked to design a
costume for a dancer i couldn't afford
buying sewing machine so i came up with
the idea of using the crochet hook to
connect fabric together and after this
was like explosion i was crocheting
gigantic installation right away
is a process of making fabric
with one continuous loop
i travel around the world every time i
go all my projects somehow relates to
the community i'm working with
our pink house is the project i created
in avesta in sweden
this town accepted a lot of refugees
from syria and ukraine
in india we were crocheting a new skin
for homeless shelter
probably most people know my work
because of the wall street bull i
appreciate pink camouflage as the
respond to the recent market crash that
happened 2008.
[Music]
currently i'm working on a project i
love across the usa
i want to create a mural in every state
that portrays women that change american
history
i always create squares or rectangles
sometimes and then when i have enough
pieces i crochet piece by piece together
with the help of the local people who
want to be part of this action
so first i touch this i go through this
and then just go on a live and install
it
people want to be part of something
and i love seeing that hunger
that
people have
to create something so positive not just
the image but the power that every
single loop is made by somebody's hand
[Music]
you